Gregg you started your career working on
the documentary pins with Garth Davis so
when he calls do you give him first
priority okay of course the gas one of
my oldest friends so whenever Garth
calls I know that what he's gonna be
working on he's gonna be very
interesting and something that would
interest me so you know I've worked with
Garth probably longer than I've worked
with anybody else in the world and I've
known Garth probably longer than anybody
else other than my family so so I
understand the way he works I understand
his his methodology so you know he and I
are quite in tune when it comes to
things we like so chances are if he's
interested in something the chances are
I'll probably like it Garth how was this
project presented to you for Lion I was
at Sundance Film Festival with top of
the lake actually and the producers of
that in Canning and Emile Sherman and I
were just getting together and they had
just read this article about Saru story
it just can't just come out and they
just said oh my god this is so you Garth
you should read it so I raced up to my
Lodge and I read the article and totally
fell in love a thorough story I said
guys this is fantastic
so they said okay well we'll go and try
get the rights to it and so the next day
they started trying to find out who had
the rights to his story and and I think
about a month later Emil had secured the
rights to the project and we started
getting into it so had you read his book
in the meantime book hadn't come out at
all so this is very early on so it was
just a it was it was it was an article
in the press so to come out went through
had just found his mother so that's all
we had read so when we started when we
got the rights we started to research
the project his book came out somewhere
along the line after that Luke was lying
on a writing assignment for you how were
you pitch to your screenplay I had a
previous relationship with the producers
Seif Cecil films because one of those
producers Emile Sherman had produced a
film that I wrote candy with Heath
Ledger ten years earlier so we had a
prior relationship basically and a
professional
affection and a respect and friendship
so they came to me here's this book what
do you think that was how it happened
and I read this book and I was like what
do I think this is like a beautiful
fairy tale with elements of Nightmare
and redemptive qualities it's like a
myth and like what I think is I really
hope that I get this job I'm gonna try
and write a structure and I hope I'm the
one you guys want and and I got it and
then it was really fast
Luke congratulations you got the job
jump on a plane so Roos in India you're
going to India he's going to show you
all the real places where everything
happened the train station the orphanage
his hometown the dam the station the
platform the rain tank and most of all I
met his mother his biological mother and
spent a few hours with her which was an
extraordinary experience so you'd never
heard of the book or Saru story
previously well by coincidence the that
the book came out when the book came out
there were articles about it online and
in the four days or so before that phone
call when they said can you check this
book and tell us what you think I had
read the story so there was this tiny
little moment where I said oh I've read
about that this week that's kind of an
amazing story the guy the Google Earth
thing so there's a really vague thing
where I had glanced at something that
was kind of just this viral like thing
that you glanced at like that that's
kind of cool
and then four days later they were like
we've got this book you know about this
story so yeah I did I knew about it this
much and then at what point are you
actually sitting down meeting Saru maybe
even going to India so as soon as we got
the rights the first thing I said is I
need to go to India and start retracing
his steps and and feeling just feeling
his story and coincidentally at the time
Australian 60 minutes was doing a an
article on Saru and they were taking the
adopted mother sue to make the birth
mother Pamela for the first time so I
was there when they were filming that
and that was my first day in my research
trip so I was suddenly kind of thrust
very deeply into this family's life and
experience and yeah kind of saw some
crazy things that was amazing
so that was my first day in the research
and then from that point on I kind of
retraced young Sara's journey I mean on
some trains I went to Calcutta I went to
the orphanages I wandered around the
streets at night imagining what I'd be
like for him to be living on these
streets I mean I have children myself so
the whole that holux journey for me was
very impactful and then I went to Hobart
and metal his contemporary friends hung
out with John Sarah's father and just
trying to immerse myself in in their
life as much as possible and what
timeframe is that that you're actually
kind of sinking in Sarah's world Oh God
look I probably spent I think the trip
was like three weeks probably and then I
would continue on with some
conversations and phone calls skypes and
then I would revisit some of these
places again as well okay and then you
somehow presented this idea to Luke or
how did this yes so I started the
research trip and then the three of us
Amelie and myself we started to look at
different writers and we all really
loved Luke and so we engaged with Luke
and at a certain point he became
officially engaged with the project and
then we quickly sent him on a same trip
I did so at least we could be on the
same page when we got together to talk
about the film so when you meet someone
that you'll be essentially duplicating
their life on screen and I'm sure all
the pressures that go along with that
what questions are you asking them or
are you merely just observing them it it
wasn't like I had a prepared set list of
questions like so I'm about to sort of
rape and pillage your life and steal
your psyche and do this thing but it
also wasn't like observational it was
like this it was like a really
interesting intense three week two or
three week research trip where I spent a
week and a half with him going around
India and then we flew to Tasmania and I
met his adoptive parents and the places
that he grew up in Hobart and so on so
it wasn't just observational it was
actually just a lot of downtime we're
just getting to know someone and
interacting I mean
literally became like okay so I'll see
you I'll see you here for breakfast like
so we want to meet down here and for
dinner and all the downtime things
between the scheduled stuff which was
like tomorrow we're going on the train
from here to here to see what the trains
are like and then we're going to the
orphanage and we're doing this where
that was all very but the other thing
was just pleasantly getting to know this
guy who's really
he's an unusually self-possessed guy you
know I think the vast majority of us are
on some sort of scale where we like to
be liked we'd like to get on with other
people and we have social contracts
about how we behave and so on Saru is
weirdly like you couldn't really tell he
doesn't care what other people think
about him and I think that's because he
had such a one in a zillion
extraordinary experience of compressed
trauma at an age where it shouldn't have
happened to anyone that it turned him
into a certain kind of human being that
has this self-contained thing and
doesn't need the approval of other in
order to sort of survive he's he's in
her life a really interesting thing is
that whenever he's with Sue this is my
observation his mother his adoptive
mother it's like a lock that opens this
door where he's closer to that
vulnerable wilded frightened
five-year-old boy so it's kind of like
he grew up he only had five years in
India then he became a really Ozzy guy
some of that means you're a bit of a lad
bit shut down Australian males you know
like it's not too in touch with your
emotions or whatever and he's a little
bit of that but he's also a guy who had
one of the most emotional sort of mythic
stories that you could experience so
he's got all that within him and his
beautiful adoptive mother sue is like
the doorway to that where you see suru
change when he's with her cuz I think
she's just so deeply part of the journey
of where he came from and where he got
to when you're making a film about
someone's life and you've met this
person you've met their family you've
traveled to their homeland how much
pressure responsibility do you feel huge
amounts yeah I did documentary once in
my early years and
really felt that responsibility in a
visceral way and I mean you know it's
something I'm very conscious of and so
you know that's why I really did have to
spend a lot of time and I think I said
to sue look maybe we're not gonna get
the story perfectly right like a
documentary you know you just can't you
know it's kind of a compressed version
of it but I hope that I get it
emotionally right for you and I hope
that you feel proud about the message it
comes out of it out of out of your story
because that's that's really what I was
hoping to get out of it so it kind of
simplifies what you're trying to
represent for them so yeah but that's
yeah but it's a huge responsibility how
many people have you met that have been
similar like that in terms of self
contained that you can just tell they're
they're almost their own Island when
they're in a public setting I've met no
unlike so he's he's there's something
really unusual about he's he's bearing
and I know and I don't mean he's cut off
he's really friendly he's really funny
he's he's full of one-liners
he's a very wry observer of human
foibles
he's extremely charming it's like he
just you know he can sweep the ladies
off their feet you know what I mean his
focus these are interesting qualities he
came out of this place that was pure
survival and peril
you know he's spoken about that people
ask him about his emotions as a five
year old he's like wait emotions were a
luxury for that period of time I had to
have a hide as thick as an elephant hide
skin and what was going on was
second-by-second black and white yes no
left-right decisions emotions were like
far far away in that situation I think
some of his journey was about
suppressing the trauma of that and then
for 25 years because he landed in this
beautiful deal with his beautiful people
and John and Sue are beautiful people
they always had the vision we're gonna
there are enough children suffering in
the world we're going to adopt children
we're not going to
our own children that was like their
vision in life and they stuck to it but
but and so Saru had that deep that in
his background and so he kept it a
secret that all those years he dreamed
every night he imagined kind of like
astral traveling back to India to get
back to his mother and brother and to
say I'm here I'm sorry I got lost you
know it's in Kuenn I just to say those
words I'm sorry I got lost it's so
touching because it wasn't his fault
what happened it's one of the movie one
of the things that makes the movie so
intensely beautiful because it wasn't
his fault he was just really vulnerable
and he made one single decision he
stepped on a train and and a catastrophe
began that completely changed his life
that ended up being okay but it wasn't
okay while it was happening and so yeah
that makes him that's part of what makes
him so so different from the rest of us
right I've seen a few interviews and I
definitely see that quality in him and I
would imagine he would be very good at
sort of reading emotions because that's
probably at the base of it how he
survived it's a survival skill right
yeah you've got to get really good at
reading people such as the scene in the
movie with the the you know who is that
guy is he a child sex trafficker and
Saru has said maybe I'm wrong I might
have been misreading that situation but
I don't think so and you're basically
like yeah none of us think so either
you weren't misreading that situation
right and the way you set it up to
because the woman was so you thought
always finally found someone he can
trust yeah but I don't want to give away
too much hair the look of Lion is
incredible especially the opening shots
I mean it really brings you into this
like supernatural feel
how are you setting the tone in the
beginning knowing that there's various
layers to the film parts of the story
the one thing that's beautiful about
Lion it's it's a very spiritual film you
know that the boy who becomes a man and
his essence is a spiritual being that
that it's constantly striving to get
home and
one of the points that Garth raised when
we first started speaking about this
opening sequence was the story that that
Saru told Garth which was often when he
was a child he would Astro travel or
what he thought was that he would as he
was going to bed he would leave his body
he would float across Australia float
across the sea and then go home his body
like this is how every every every night
he kind of imagined this would happen
and it wasn't until he discovered Google
Maps which became the physical you know
incarnation of what he was trying to do
that he actually then realized he was
onto something
but but that opening sequence was
effectively his spirit going home you
know as starts in Tasmania and it
travels across Australia it goes across
an ocean lands in India goes across
India train tracks goes across
landscapes and then down into him so
it's him getting home so in some ways
you could you believe it's you know it's
his spirit beginning the movie and it's
a really lovely way to start the movie
by by his spirit beginning the film when
you finally sat down to assemble the
script are you consulting with him or is
it becoming a finished product and then
Saru here you go
or none of that yeah it was more the
latter it was so then so that was really
handy to meet him to travel around with
him to get a sense of who he was and
then it was like so now I'm in this
place with goth then goth and I came
together so now it's about your loyalty
towards trying to create a film that
he's a rollicking good yarn gripping
compelling and in yes of course at the
same time having a kind of moral and
ethical duty towards the fact that
you're dealing with real people's lives
very much still alive but he wasn't part
of that process then until it was like
here's the script and what was really
surprising was that he's basically his
reaction was it was kind of like oh okay
cool so this is what a script is like
that's interesting I didn't know this is
what a screenplay looks like all these
technical things that you've got to work
out what does that mean
exterior you know day you know all that
technical stuff he didn't actually have
a lot to say about well that didn't
happen or that didn't happen or I feel
uncomfortable about that there was very
very little sue his mother for example
said I thought you should have made the
orphanage stuff darker oh we thought
that often in scenes were pretty damn
dark what's going on in there is you
know very troubling and unpleasant some
aspects of it
not mrs. Sood the wonderful lady who
comes and rescues him obviously yeah but
no sir was just like okay I get it
we through and his mum and dad John and
Sue I mean they were like we understand
that not everything's exactly like what
happened but we completely touched by
your capturing of the emotional truth of
the story and the stuff that we tweaked
they understood that too that they were
learning about decisions you have to
make in filmmaking okay like for example
trivial level in real life Saru
basically drove three girlfriends crazy
in his five-year search for home you
know we've got the it's much better to
have Rooney Mara one character not three
we don't we didn't need three
girlfriends to sort of tell the same
story and he was like ah okay ah so
that's the kind of thing you do in film
making decisions that's cool and then in
terms of actors I know you'd said
previously that there's so many great
ones but you wanted ones that you knew
could carry the emotionality of so many
of the scenes you talked about what you
were looking for specifically in terms
of that emotion well first and foremost
I needed people to connect to the story
in a way that I felt would honor the
film I mean it's just it's such an
emotional film that no one can dial it
in do you not I mean so you know you
might be presented with a list --is but
if they're not totally passionate about
it I don't want them do you not I mean
so they had to be very passionate about
the story
I'm each character had a different need
so for instance what I loved about
Nicole Kidman for example is that
there's kind of a
strengthen nicole kidman that I saw in
sue this is a lot of similarities I
could start to see emotionally so I
don't know a lot of things started
become quite apparent to me when I was
dreaming the characters and meeting the
actors that it became quite obvious who
was right what what is it about the
passion and an actor well how do you how
can you tell are there are there phrases
is there body language just even when
you know that they can nail the
performance but in terms of really being
committed like that lets care about it I
can talk about it from their own point
of view they can own it they can have an
opinion they they're deep in the
material so that's really important you
know when I met Nicole in New York to
talk about the role she just spoke about
it in such a deep way and how it related
to her life and imagine that and we just
had this such deep conversation so
that's a place you're starting from I
mean of course the performances are
going to be amazing you know because
we're going to go to such deep and
honest places together so yeah it's
really important I think how is the
relationship with the subject whether
it's a documentary subject or an actor
and a narrative and the lens especially
in an intimate story like line but then
there's a lot of also wide shots but how
is that when you're trying to let's say
get a teardrop what is that like well as
a cinematographer or as a cameraman you
try to run the risk of you run the risk
of the camera impeding what's going on
now in a documentary definitely because
you don't ever want to stop something
from happening that should happen but
you also don't want to be the cause or
something to happen so good documentary
making is kind of writing that fine line
between but observing and not creating
but at the same time you know where the
line is is a is a blur sometimes with
filmmaking it's not dissimilar like you
know I was watching we were at Q & A
last night and I was actually with dev
in the green room and we're watching the
scene where he goes back and finds his
mom in India and I hadn't seen dev for
at least a year and a half actually and
I was like dude remember that it was
like yesterday but it felt so long ago
it was like yesterday like I remember
exactly as he's walking I'm walking with
him
walking back with him but I couldn't see
his mum that was a big camera another
camera but I couldn't see him I wanted
to get more into his eyes but I don't
wanna block his his view of his mum so
it's just writing the fine line between
being a passive observer but also giving
the audience what they need which is
seeing into his eyes seeing the scene
seeing everything unfold so trying to
try to make trying to try to play that
role is is quite quite hard but fun I
mean it's fantastic you know I just shot
something with Garth and we were in
Italy and I don't know I remember as a
camera operator just just being
completely magnetized why these actors
like the camera couldn't not be on them
if it was on my shoulder or on my hip it
just just like it was like literally
there was a homing beacon just like Paul
following them everywhere they went and
I understand that Sonny this is one of
his first this was one of his first
acting roles at that time well yeah he's
yeah unbelievable just five Oh and so
you saw how many children to find a
thousand boy
we passed about four to five months in
three three cities in India and then we
would look at that would we look at
those tapes coming in on Dropbox every
week and then we created a shortlist of
maybe a hundred to two hundred children
and then a group of us went over to
India and did these acting workshops for
about a week or two weeks just trying to
find our kids so when you're on set for
lion are you mostly working with the
crew or are you mostly working with the
actors where's your attention mostly
folk well it's it's it's kind of
everything the minute I arrived on set
you say good morning everyone and I the
first place I go is a wardrobe truck so
the makeup truck so I meet my actors in
the morning and say good morning and
make sure that they're comfortable with
the day ahead of them and it's the first
thing I do is say good morning to
everybody and then often the first hour
of the morning you're with the crew
because the actors are still preparing
so you're you know and then I sit with
my DP and we have 10 minutes together
and I talked about and the ad and we
just talked about
the morning's work and what we're trying
to achieve and then we walk to set and
then we then we all go off independently
and work with our crew so there's
definitely a rhythm that I have when I'm
working that seems to have worked for me
how many of the shots were handheld
versus I don't know the ratio probably
half I'd say but they were definite
times that we wanted to stop the camera
from being handheld so there are
different times where his story slows so
the camera needs to slow his story of
stops he takes rest he you know he's
taking taking in the world around him so
we need to make sure that the cameras
load at at that point as well so that
was a often used stereo camera long lens
or or dolly so you filmed in two
countries I believe so Tasmania which is
what an island in Australia is is the
southernmost island off the bottom of
Australia okay and then in India was it
Calcutta or but we also filmed in Ken
wah which is where he's from so you know
the story takes place in two cities in
India and two cities in Melbourne
that's Kendra in Calcutta and Hobart and
Melbourne so we filmed in India between
Calcutta and in Canberra and then we
also filmed between Hobart Melbourne now
are you shooting a lot of it sort of in
chronological order in terms of his life
I mean pretty much I mean we shot India
first and we shot Australia second
it was almost chronological we shot in
Calcutta all the stuff in Calcutta first
and then we moved out to the villages so
it wasn't wasn't that linear but I mean
Dev Patel 'he's first scene was when he
met his mother and the end of the movie
oh wow okay so there was very nonlinear
moments but I think by shooting India
first we were able to learn a lot from
that and take take the textures and the
colors and the visual language that were
created there into the contemporary
story so I think was great shooting in
your first so each day when you're
reporting to set how early is this that
you're going
and what's that one that's a good
question it's a very done depending on
the day because obviously there were
some days that we needed to go into
night time and there were certain limits
that you can only work with the with
sunny of course because he's like he's a
young boy and you know not to mention us
old timers having to get to bed early
and stuff like that so we needed to with
that change on a daily basis depending
on what we what we were shooting first
day of shooting
where was this the first week were night
shoots with sunny five-year-old sunny in
the train station okay the Train scenes
you talked about some of the technical
aspects how you live the scene well film
in trends is very tricky because
classically you know that very narrow
carriages to walk in they don't give you
any more walk way than you need as a
passenger so to try and move up and down
them is very hard with a camera it's
very hard particularly when you're
slightly larger than your average Indian
moving trains are typical because they
they definitely throw the camera around
a lot so keeping a steady image is quite
hard
we used a used a gimbal for a lot of the
moving camera work in India so we had an
airy REM on the gimbal so we had a great
gimbal operator Brett from from
Melbourne come and join us in India and
he would basically just just run run
with a boy and the good thing about that
game was I could operate as well so I
could he could hold the camera in the
right spot or move it and then I could
with the wheels I could pan and tilt and
follow him
so it was the closest thing to having
like a remote head but on legs rather
than a dolly or rather than a crane or
or a Russian arm so you start with the
night shoots at the train station and
how was that especially because Sony's
so young and this is one of his I mean
there must have been overwhelming for
him this huge crew or I don't know yeah
I mean it was we're all just learning
the language and learning how we all
work together so you know you just
stumble through it and the minute you
get it like maybe you just find a moment
that's really special
you just know that you're on the right
path
and you just build upon those
experiences and confidence and that you
know the way you move together as a crew
becomes easier and so very quickly you
just tune in to what the films going to
be but you know up at that point your I
was imagining how it could be and that's
all hypothetical until you're literally
making the thing so the reality of
working with a child working in India or
that comes to a head at that moment and
so it's kind of terrifying exciting at
the same time we were asking Gregg how
it was to be there with this camera and
he said that actually most of the people
around were used to productions being
around there can you talk about maybe
using some of the people that were maybe
not extras they were actual talented
people yeah look I mean I think Calcutta
was easier to shoot in and say Mumbai
because they're just not I mean they're
not they're not as exposed to movies as
people in Mumbai so you know they get
curious but a lot of the times people
they've got to catch the train they're
going to move on so every 20 minutes
you'd get a new wave of people so if
someone started to look there's a
certain point they've got to go and
catch the train so I don't know it kind
of worked for us we would you know we
would definitely have extras there that
we would put into the foreground and
then have live crowds in the background
at the ticket box scene we were when
when he's being kind of you know ignored
and shoved out of the way when he's
trying to ask for help we we controlled
the first three or four ticket boxes and
then the rest down the end was just real
tickets being sold so um because we're
working in live locations so we kind of
got the scale that way just working very
cleverly within the width in real spaces
how was it in India filming when it
seemed like there were people that were
really from the town these weren't
actual extras and how were they in terms
of seeing this machine this this thing
that maybe they don't see every day or
maybe they do well I don't know people
generally a very inquisitive in India at
a vast generalization some people
couldn't care that we were there but
some people were absolutely like
intrigued by this thing that we had
everybody knows that the process of
filmmaking
I mean you know it India makes more
films I think than any other country in
the planet I think they're there they're
the most prolific when it comes to
filmmaking so to believe that people
don't really know what's going on it's
kind of quite wrong because everyone
knows what's happening exactly the
process of filmmaking I think that's
were part of the entertainment they were
on the streets were part of the
entertainment
you know if somebody was at the train
station there it may be at the train
station waiting for a train for hours
what else did they have to do like we
were part of the part of the sideshow so
trying to make sure that we weren't we
were giving everybody the entertainment
that they needed but weren't they
weren't getting in the way was part of
the challenge for us what was the
largest crew you were working with and
what location was that in terms of Lion
yeah the largest crew I mean probably I
mean probably the one of the biggest
things we did in India was closing down
the Howrah bridge so that's never been
done before and it's the sequence where
little Saru escapes from the child
Snatchers and he runs out of the train
station and emerges onto the bridge and
it's kind of overcome by the scale of
the bridge he's never seen anything like
that before
and he's almost too afraid to cross it
because of the scale of it and he then
goes to the side and sees the bother
shrine so that bridge we had to get
permission to control that so he had
obviously have a lot of traffic
management at either end of the bridge
so that was probably the biggest
logistical thing that we did and then
there are other times we're shooting
something quite small but we had
thousands of people looking at us and
that kind of consumed a lot of resources
just trying to control the crowd as well
but it was fairly simple shoot like we
didn't use any lighting very small
amounts of lighting we shot with two
cameras I mean it's all pretty basic
stuff
Greg can we talk about the lighting kit
and how it varied from the Train versus
outdoors one of the challenging things
on this movie which is also one of the
great things was that we were quite
limited in resources you know we
we went to India we we didn't want to
carry around with us truck loads of
equipment because in the end it never it
wouldn't actually have helped us to have
you know hundreds of lights and the
ability to like that would have actually
slowed us down so what I tried to do is
we tried to find locations that had a
had a base level of natural light that
looks really nice we did carry some H of
Mines because we had a couple of scenes
where we had hm eyes come through
windows but for the most part we used we
used LEDs we had one Pelican case with
three LED heads in it and we lit
predominantly most of India with three
small LED heads so we even the outdoor
scenes not just I mean the outdoor
scenes at night yes but the outdoor
scenes during the day I mean it's rare
my style of lighting would really bring
out lights for outdoors I mean there's
it'd be very rare for me to do that so
no I wouldn't pull LEDs out for the
daytime I'd go with natural light and
then control the natural and how did you
deal with sound it's a good question
Nakul our sound recordist in India I
think was a bit of a genius he may have
even been nominated for an Oscar I think
at some point but he was just a
wonderful sound recordist and you'll
even notice the actors when they're in a
scene if they hear a train horn they'll
just pause and then they'll continue the
line after the train so like everyone's
very aware of sound but you couldn't
hide from it we had to do a lot of
cleanup but the sound of course was very
good is extremely good so that first
shot of the day or night
but but it's the first one that you've
set up how is that in terms of the last
shot do you think that there's more
fluidity toward the end and you feel
more comfortable or or is it actually
are you sharper in the beginning no I
think you if it's the first part of a
sequence it's always slower because what
you're trying to do is trying to work
out what the sequence how the sequence
needs to take shape so if that happens
at the start of the day or happens at
the end of the day or towards the end of
the day I think they're pretty pretty
even evenly paced it's pretty
traditional though for for the bulk of
the work to be done later
because I think there's just something
kicks in when you're filmmakers and you
go well we're going to get four hours to
go
we should really put the put the put on
the gas so I think your your level of
the amount that you achieve is a lot
higher in the afternoon or you know the
latter part the day had you talked to
anyone else or had you personally done
any like journey back home to confront
any sort of like memories or anything
and and all that goes through that for
someone because it's a different trip
than someone who maybe has fond memories
it's much more emotional
yeah well the the thing you know it's a
one in a million kind of story because
this hasn't happened to most of us I
have continuity from childhood with my
parents and brothers and sisters and
loved ones that even if that means I
don't have there's not an unexplained
emotional journey if I've understood
your question correctly that I had to go
back and experience so I had to use my
imagination I just had to have my own
memories and interestingly enough Google
Earth going back to my childhood Street
was vividly incredible in terms of
memories of being five years old when we
moved into that Street I was three years
old so I don't have memories of the
house before that from zero to three I
only have memories of that Street that
house and they and they and they're
really really vivid and Google Earth was
like oh my god that's the street that's
the curve that's where we did that
that's where we played it you know this
and that and and I had to use the leaps
of the imagination to think man could at
five years old could I have done any of
this no food no money no clothes no
nothing you know in a world full of
perils and predators have helped and
also we live in a us you me everybody we
live in first world countries where if
five-year-old kids are wandering around
the street distressed it gets dealt with
pretty quickly this does not happen in
India there are bands of feral Street
kids and if they try and harass any
adults they get battered away it's just
it's the way of life it's the chaos it's
the poverty it's the extraordinary other
work
enos of india that is so not what what
we know our privileged first world
reality and Sensibility
so the leap of the imagination into what
that must have been like is immense and
for me it's just hats off to Garth Davis
the director because he made that leap
he brought it to life it's like my
script was just this way station at the
beginning of the process but to me he
did such a beautiful job that when I
watched the movie now even though I
wrote it and I know what happens every
second I cry every time I watch it
because I'm I'm an observer of goths
beautiful work of art you know and he
created all these magic moments that
took the leap of the imagination and
make you feel what it's like to be in
such danger in peril and trying to
survive in terms of Google Earth how
familiar were you with it I mean I know
it's been around what a decade I guess
before actually delving into the shots
and figuring out the older version of it
yes a Google Earth I mean I use all the
time for location searching anyway in
commercials and so Google Earth is a
tool that I use as much as I do with
Microsoft Word but you know I think what
was I mean it's it's a risk having
anything computerized in your movie I
mean there's nothing more boring than
looking at a mobile phone or a computer
screen in a film but I think in this
instance it was kind of really exciting
to to take the power of his past and his
yearning and his you know all of that
into these computer into these computer
images you know of into Google Earth and
to see these maps passing through so it
suddenly became very loaded and
interesting and haunting and the fact
that it was low resolution and it didn't
work very fast there kind of the texture
of it for me was like memory and so
suddenly something got quite excited
about the software and how it became
this strange window into his past so it
was it was great challenge to kind of
bring that software to life in a way
that was meaningful so you're dealing
with human beings but then you're also
dealing with Google Earth which is a
completely other you know
how much research are you doing into
Google Earth how familiar had you
already been with the program I didn't
personally have to I was really familiar
with the program when Google Earth came
out I - like many people went to my
childhood home and worked out and
memories came flooding back you know
that was the creek where I used to play
with my brothers and oh in that all
these houses that used to be bushland
and all of that you know I did that and
but like so at a scriptwriting level
what I knew was that we had this tale
that felt like an ancient tale like it
felt like an ancient myth or an ancient
fairy tale that goes back to the
earliest origins of like humans
storytelling you know like reunification
with the lost mother and yet this was a
story that in the whole history of human
civilization could never have happened
until 10 years ago until Google released
Google Earth we wouldn't be sitting here
right now if that app had not been
released because he could never have
found home the way he did with these
four or five or six visual memories that
he need to basically geo locate from
space and so to me it was like oh my god
it's an old myth and a new myth and so
what a beautiful challenge to get that
in there and if we handle the first half
of the film really well if we're inside
the reality and the distress and peril
and bewilderment and fear and
determination of this five-year-old boy
then in the second half when it gets
more interior and psychologically we're
going to experience that as being
exactly the same person on an unfinished
interrupted journey the interruption
happens to be 25 years but we should be
feeling like we're in the same person
and and it's and the technology it's not
like most films where technologies like
logistical kind of plot development
stuff the the liberation for us was that
we knew that the technological stuff the
Google Earth stuff is part of the
emotional journey so that you hopefully
the audience you feeling it in in your
gut basically but at the level of
research I didn't have to do much I just
tried to write the Google stuff
poetically this is what he's seeing on
screen this is what he's seeing on
screen
because I trusted that seesaws a great
company and that they'll work out the
tech details properly and what happened
was they had very little to do with
Google Earth except that the Google
Earth coding guys helped make the Google
screen stuff completely authentic and
period authentic from the actual times
that Saru was searching so they went in
this guy described it to me we went to
Google headquarters all of us it was
really fun day and he described it as
the archaeology of the coding they had
to go in like archaeologists to the
coding of the earlier versions of Google
and they weren't sure if they would
succeed in properly recreating what
Google Earth was like at any given time
and they got it down to fine detail they
worked out the timelines of when Saru
was looking at so if you're a tech geek
it's completely authentic every single
time you see Google Earth on screen in
the film it tracks the time of when Saru
was actually searching the stuff in the
very beginning it's the super slow
buffering speeds through remember the
frustrations of the early days of Google
Earth now it's great and it was the low
resolution when you zoom down to the low
levels and so on so they recreated that
it's kind of cool like it's cool in a
sort of once we need to know the tech
stuff way yeah with the Google Earth
shots were those actual shots that
you're filming from a computer screen at
times yep yep at times we I think there
was some I think there was some
computer-generated shots at times but I
think for the most part we were trying
to film off a computer screen because
it's just we wanted to give it a texture
I wanted to make sure there was texture
reflections like we wanted it not to be
a flat kind of you know like info doc oh
that okay he looks at this then he looks
at here he looks here it wasn't about
that it's about the emotions so trying
to link that with him was really
important trying to see reflections
trying to see his face through
reflections trying to see the screen
changed light on his face in his eyes
and his tears like it was you know some
beautiful moments where we we had some
great reflections in a tear I remember
watching it like a close-up on his eyes
and the tearin' down I went
I saw the map I saw the mechanist here
thank ya that was great - yeah seeing
him with the laptop and but how is that
in terms of the technical you know that
the lens picking up the screen because I
know maybe in the olden days you would
definitely see like that yeah yeah I
think that's because no different
monitors CRT monitors that that refresh
I think LCDs or LED monitors don't
refresh anymore I think I'm not that
techie when it comes to that but I know
that traditionally laptop monitors I've
really had a problem with did you take
any train rides either by yourself in
India or with the masses of the sea in
one scene where it just looks
overwhelming yeah well I did we went to
how our our station the main station
where Saru got spat out in Calcutta and
that was amazing for research also
that's the station where they shot all
the scenes so that the the real place is
the place where it really happened about
up in Madhya Pradesh province I the home
village yeah we went on like a four-hour
train ride and back just to get a sense
just for my research it was like I
wanted to get a sense of the chaos of
the trains and the seating arrangements
and the structures just to help with
basic technical stuff of how to write
what's going on in the trains and what's
going on on the stations and the
fundamental thing of any travel
experience in India if you've been there
is that it is exhausting every single
thing is so kind of chaotic and I mean
maybe I'm sounding like a wimp here but
travelling in India is both exhilarating
and exhausting at every single level
from the smallest detail to the largest
at the end of the day which scene of
Lion are you most proud of so many
beautiful scenes and such a journey but
look I do love the scene with Sue and
Saru just the two hander which he talks
about the vision of the ghost and how
she could have had children I just
thought that was when I was filming that
I was unaware of where I was I was so
like I was lost in her performance so
that's pretty exciting when that happens